[Music]
why is the administration flying
thousands of migrants from the border to
florida and new york in the middle of
the night
uh well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night but let me tell you
what's happening here um it is our
very early in the morning
that's a confirmation though that's the
white house confirming the new york post
report that the bide administration has
been secretly flying underage migrants
to florida and new york in the middle of
the night i happen to think 2 and 4 a.m
although i often get up at 4 a.m
fox and friends in the middle of the
night and for all that we know it might
not just be limited to those states
buses there are waiting to take them to
prearrange drop-off locations and
there's no end in sight to this
self-created border crisis as reports
are coming in that the quote mother of
all caravans self-named
is heading towards biden's open border
joining me now is nationally syndicated
radio host dana lash along with the new
york post columnist who broke this story
miranda devine ladies thank you both for
being with me tonight miranda fill me in
on a few of these details so planes in
the middle of the night landing in
westchester and other places dropping
people off i assume after being picked
up at the southern border of the united
states
that's right we've just followed that
route from
from texas from the southern border
to white plains and they come via
jacksonville florida where they drop off
some of their migrants and then
they arrive in the dead of night as you
said and the the curfew at that white
plains airport is midnight and these
planes are flying in way after curfew
and then there are charter buses and a
police escort waiting for them and we
just observed uh two flights from
westchester and one from into
westchester and one
that left jacksonville that came to
white plains
last week and of those we saw about a
hundred migrants come off each plane and
we we followed a couple of buses that
went one to long island to drop some of
these migrants off at about 1am at a
sort of a group home a former orphanage
now they have a contract there mercy
first
with the federal government to house
migrant youth um
there were
several adults that as far as i could
see in my photographer could see that
came off these planes as well the
government is telling us they're all
children but it doesn't look like that
to us but regardless it's all been done
secretly and and if the the federal
government was not trying to hide what
they were doing they would
show us who was on the plane and they
would tell us where they were taking
them and they wouldn't be doing these
flights in the dead of night it seems
indisputable that they're doing this
secretly why else break curfew why else
do it all through the night and dana
we're not talking about necessarily
large numbers of people but what seems
to be escaping our policy makers or the
people who refuse to make policy is the
idea of incentive if it is that you can
cross the border and if you then get
shipped wherever you want to go why
would you be surprised then that a
caravan of 95 000 people is set to
launch in mexico in the next couple of
days they're calling it by the way the
madre caravana the mother of all
caravans
i think you're exactly right will and
and it is an incentive i mean when they
when people see that there's there's no
law order that's being enforced not just
at the border but in the interior and i
thought miranda's story was fantastic my
you know my question as a parent was
well where are the parents of these
children these these minors that are
being transported up to new york and
then put on buses thereafter do we even
know where they're going have any local
officials been made aware i mean that's
a that's a very serious issue but will
further to your point with the border
you're going to have more children that
are going to be coming up towards the
border they're going to be taken by
coyotes and taken across the border or
trafficked i mean that's the other thing
we don't even know about the safety or
well-being of these kids and this is
supposed to be in the name of some kind
of fake compassion from this
administration about the plight of these
people that are trying to seek entry
into the united states i mean if it's
about compassion that there would be
some sort of regular order that people
could follow and we could verify to see
who they were and make sure that yes
they are a family unit and these
children are their children and maybe
you could stay and apply for asylum and
follow the process like every other
person will that's ever had to immigrate
to this country uh and that's
it's a complete breakdown so of course
it's an incentive and we're going to
have this problem again and again and
again and this administration won't fix
it so what are those details miranda
like dana just asked you know where are
they going why are they alone can you i
guess as a migrant simply say i would
like to be dropped off in new york and
you have a private chartered flight do
so is it you say my parents are in new
york and therefore you're put on a plane
why i mean the details of how this comes
together logistically are mystifying
yes and if you just you just have to
look at the publicly available flight
logs to see that this is happening all
over the country there are several hubs
around the country and these planes
because you're not going to leave you
know upwards of one and a half million
illegal migrants down by the border
because it would be a catastrophe so
they have to disperse them quietly
around the country into communities that
don't know what's going on and uh we've
seen there we watched one
one bus take a or two buses actually
from one flight take a bunch of these
migrants on wednesday night to and drop
them off at a rest area off the new
jersey turnpike now if they were
children this was really failure of the
duty of care of hhs because they didn't
check the identification of any of the
people that came up in cars to pick
these people up how do we know who they
are oh well we know uh tom holman from
who was you know border security under
donald trump said that they spent an
inordinate amount of time vetting
the people that would would come and
pick up unaccompanied minors but that's
been shortchanged right with this
government and they're not talking
really quickly dana i just want to give
the quick last word there's no doubt
this changes the fabric of america is it
intended to do so
uh i don't in terms of we need people to
come in legally not illegally your first
act under the country shouldn't be
breaking a law i mean it is the melting
pot i know that's not the pc term to use
anymore but we're a country that's
founded around the principles of freedom
not racial identity but we're also a
republic founded on law and order